rachel mcintosh spent the days leading
up to christmas isolating with her
brother after catching covet for the
second time
it wasn't nearly as bad as the first few
days uh the first time around the 31
year old likely first contracted the
delta variant in late april and in
december omicron
some of the numbers that we've seen
suggest that if you're infected with
sars cov2 you have about three months
where you're really resistant to
reinfection
in canada under testing has made it
almost impossible to track our
re-infection rates but testing is widely
available in denmark between november
21st and february 11th 1.8 million danes
32 percent of their population tested
positive for covid a study under peer
review from state and serum institute
noted more than 1700 were re-infections
researchers also found in rare cases
some caught omicron twice in a sample
size of over 100 000 there were 47
instances where someone tested positive
for both the original strain of omicron
ba1 and the now dominant in denmark ba2
even when we saw reinfections it was
mainly unvaccinated young people so
that'll kind of reassure you that if you
are vaccinated
then you have quite a good protection
again this phenomenon
this bodes well for us with 84 percent
of eligible canadians fully vaccinated
the risk of reinfection at least over
the short term few months ahead is very
very small but that doesn't mean we
aren't susceptible to another mutation
rachel says she's done her part to avoid
a third boat i had three vaccines so i
even had the booster shot prepared as
best she can should we see another wave
jamie morocco global news toronto